[Musique]
retour en france avec une première
ouverture dans le conflit des
universités
les négociations ont commencé avec la
ministre valérie pécresse et l'unef
évoque ce soir des avancées importantes
dans le même temps les manifestations
organisées dans les grandes villes ont
rassemblé quelques trente mille
étudiants et lycéens au total mallory
jaun ou diane richard
l'abrogation avant toute négociation
le seul mot d'ordre dans les rues de
paris et des grandes villes de france
ils sont plusieurs milliers d étudiants
et autant de lycéens rassemblés contre
la loi d'autonomie des universités
au service d'edf au service du patronat
il n'y a rien de bon à dire soit un
quart d'heure on ne peut pas l'aménager
et pourtant au ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur on discute cet
après midi valérie pécresse a reçu cinq
organisations étudiantes dont l'unef et
a fait des annonces outre la hausse de
budget de 50% en cinq ans confirmé hier
elle a promis un cadrage national des
diplômes pour limiter la concurrence
entre facultés un texte sur l'absence de
sélection à l'entrée l'université et un
sixième échelon de bourse dès janvier
cent mille étudiants sont concernés il
n'est pas question de retraite 30
universités veulent passer à l'autonomie
d'ici l'année prochaine cette loi elle
est incontournable elle est vitale pour
l'université et à la sortie l'unef se
dit rassuré les étudiants doivent
intégrer que s'agit pour eux d'avancées
notables obtenue grâce à la mobilisation
il leur appartient une fine et de
décider s'il faut ou pas poursuivre la
mobilisation ces annonces auront tel un
effet dans les assemblées générales ici
à montpellier le blocage a été levé mais
la grève votée à nouveau
à rennes les bloqueurs ont encore montré
leur détermination en fin d'après midi
une quarantaine d'universités et plus de
100 lycées restent touchés
[Musique]